you
well hello everybody uh welcome back to
another live stream here on free
code camp and i am sam with python
basics
and all right so last time
i commented on why
you should i said don't over copy code
and i said
and i and i can't believe i did it and i
slipped her and i said oh we can copy
this
it's the same
these two are not the same so that's why
it failed
over and over and over again don't copy
code so see what happens
well i'm glad to be back everybody uh
jan how are you doing with
your issue with um your string and your
character changes
uh i hope that hope you're making some
progress on that but i'm glad to be back
today
on this tuesday so today what we're
going to be doing
is we're going to be building upon
everything we know so we are going to
start with a times table
and yeah that sounds oh it's just going
to be columns and rows
yeah but then we're going to learn to
it's going poorly
but uh all right i i can i can help some
and then we'll
toy around we're actually going to look
at some f string today
uh padding um air handling
while loop uh we're gonna throw in some
break and then
uh we're gonna look at prime numbers
we're gonna do what i think is some
pretty cool stuff some really good
basic thinking planning laying out
so let's just go ahead and get into it
so glad to have everybody here
uh we got some people who've been around
a while that is awesome because then
we start to build um a relationship and
a cadence
and then we we can really start start
solving some problems so all right
uh everything looks good coming through
so let's just get after it
oh and if time allows may we build a
little
cool thing that we can do but like i was
saying
um this is our third this is our third
stream
and we've done some stuff and i just
realized that i told you i was gonna do
it
and i haven't done it yet but i promise
i'll get all this code
and i actually saved the shell last time
so i'm actually going to then upload
that to
my github so we can um you guys if
you've missed anything
can come back and watch and pull the
code and see what it is
all right let's go ahead and just get
into it
so first let's let's let's build us
a times table let's comment all this out
we don't need anything
to print to the screen let's make sure
we're good all right awesome
hey and if i have not said this yet to
this group but don't ever delete code
just comment it out you're going to want
to see
something that you wrote and you're like
what how'd i handle this and also
i think it's very very very important to
see your evolution
and how that goes so all right
times table so let's think about
how we need to do this because we're
going to run into some problems
because i know you can get a times table
up on the screen
but how are we going to handle
one repeatability if we want to do it
again and two
what happens if the user makes a mistake
so let's just jump into it
times table
if i can spell if i haven't said that
yet i'm not the world's best speller
i'd actually comment that i'm probably
the world's worst speller
so all right let me click over see if we
got any
thank you quincy i appreciate that um
nice to
nice to see you here um that's that's
awesome
i like that all right so we got to think
about it
um what do we want to have happen
so we're going to get we're going to get
rows and columns out so
let's handle that first for
okay uh for row
well first we need to handle input from
the user
i'm getting ahead of myself i'm sorry
guys so
input please let's get this out of your
way
please enter
a number so what is the first problem
we're going to have
right here what is the very first
problem we're going to have
with this if i'm working with numbers
what is my first
problem with input
anybody got any thoughts jan i think
you've helped us with this before
shoot i need to maybe my kids are right
maybe i do need a third monitor
all right so our first problem is going
to be if we
go and try to multiply this
so if i go print x
times 3
actually we ran into that last time
divided by 2
times
table let me click over i bet somebody's
already answered
bingo yep
so if i enter a number i get
all kinds of problem because
the default and this is how we can know
you can
if you're super brand new which is the
point of this
help help help help help help
python has some awesome awesome help
um string it is
prop gives you standard output
string and it drops all the trailing so
we need to wrap this
we need to wrap this up int so now
i can get this and i give it six
okay cool so we're done there
now we're going to take this and if i
want a times table if i want a times
table
of we're just start small and then we'll
build up to
how to handle um multiple digits
so all right for row
we're going to just lay this out
and we're going to have another problem
for row in
range x
now so we got our rows and then we've
done this before
so then then what do we need to do
we're then going to have a loop inside a
loop because we're going to come down
but we also then need to go column
for column in range
still x
then now here's where it gets fun
print
row times
column now we got all kinds of fun stuff
problems here okay anybody remember
how we start solving this
anybody remember what we do here
so we need a suppression
i'm going to suppress the new line and
we're going to start
with an empty string
let's go small swing kinda all right so
now we got a little bit of a problem
so we've compressed we've removed all
new lines
we've removed we've suppressed all new
lines
all right so then every time after the
each new row we need to bring it we need
to reactivate it
okay we're getting close all right so
now
okay so i want one space in between
all the letters excuse me all the
numbers
all right uh oh here's our first dilemma
here is our very first dilemma this is
ugly so now
now we need to use our f string so now
we're going to introduce f string
so we saw last time we use string format
we use brackets
well f string is even more simple
it is this brackets
then whatever information you want
inside the brackets
now with this little tweak right here
so i want to right now we're only gonna
handle
um up to three so we're gonna do our
colon
three because we could do two how do we
do two first
so what i did didn't close this out
all right all right
so enter four uh let's run this again in
c5
because i made a boo-boo all right so
what did i just do
inside my f string i said i want here's
my
here's my information i want my columns
and rows
multiplied and i want you to have
two i want you to give this every
number two places all right
that's what this means and if i go up to
three this is going to then
pad
if i go let's do five
so i'm going to have an extra space
right here
and now so now we're going to have
an issue right now we are just
we're just doing this one one time
actually let's do our air handling first
so now we are using this function
and we know that we need to enter
a digit all right so what happens if we
enter
a letter this is super important right
here
so whenever a computer crashes a program
crashes
a variety of things usually happen but
more than likely what happens
is a scenario happened
and air handling did not
grab that specific issue
and it crashed and most of them are
handled
but you can get enough scenarios to
happen and when you have more elaborate
applications
they go through and you can end up it's
just like
uh your streets in your town there's
millions of ways to get
to a certain location so
python has a awesome awesome awesome
tool
try and accept so we're just going to
look at it
and we know how to do this let's get
back over here
and finally yes let's handle let's
handle those errors i like that
so we can if you're super super new here
we're looking at in our interactive help
prompt and we're typing in keywords
so we're going to look at try
and let's see if i can do my alphabet
real fast e
uh except so these two are linked
together and
um someone's already pointed out about
finally but we're just gonna
we're just gonna focus on try and
basically the way that this works is
try this and if this throws an error
then do this and what is very awesome
about python is you can actually
become laser focused on what type of
error you're looking for and then what
to do
because you're going to have times where
you're going to have different errors
but we're we're doing stepping stones
we're doing
we're doing micro topics just like
everything else we do
so um great so now
so we're going to throw this in here and
we're gonna move it over
indent region okay so we're gonna go try
so we're gonna try this and then we're
gonna come out here same
same indention accept
and then what was our what was our
accept
it was a value error value error
it's on the same line value
and the e the va the v and the e are
and look there's a perfect example of me
not spelling i know i spelled it right
that looks perfectly fine to me
but it's not much
it's not purple so that is an
awesome check for me when i knew that it
was not a
term that python didn't recognize so i
didn't spell it right
all right then what do i want to have
happen
so i'm going to go we're just going to
do print and we're just going to say
oops
please enter a
number now
let's look at this all right
all right five okay now let's run it
again
oops m oops please enter a number
oh but it's still exited
so now we need to put this in a loop any
thoughts on what kind of loop this might
need to be
so it needs to be what we're going to do
is we're going to do a while loop so
it's just going to run
until we tell it to exterminate or
tell it not to or set a condition for it
to stop
so let's look and see so you could do
this
a couple of ways well two so you could
hardwire this
and say true which is what we're gonna
do or you could set it to a
if if you're having a hard time with
with um wanting to see it in your head
you could set this to
a you could set a variable at the top uh
set it to true
have that be here because we're actually
then going to
look at a keyword so we can just see
this so now we need to move this over
one more time one more time
all right so this is going to right now
this is going to do this
until something happens okay
all right
all right see
so there's but there's no way to exit
so i'm just going to be sitting here
getting times tables now let's handle
one
problem first anybody notice it yet
5 16 6
25 36.
anybody anybody notice it's in there
and the exception block do we need a
nest try and accept inside the neck
not in this scenario because i'll show
you how we're going to lay this
out and it's not going to bingo we have
to add
we need to add a plus 1 to our x but no
this is going to be sufficient
all right so here we go so let's solve
one pro
always always only change your code one
one problem one thing at a time because
if you go starting to change
i mean both of them could be wrong or
only one of them could be wrong so you
could have
either one two or four problems
four scenarios to check so change one
thing rerun your code check it
all right so we need to solve this now
so
restart shell okay so in the way that
we're going to do this
is we need to learn about um
how to break how to break out of this
there we go
and we're just going to pose this as a
question let's get this up here
yep cue
input do
you want
to want
another table
so now the way that we're going to
handle this let's do
yeah and then i do y and no
space all right
so we're gonna like always we're gonna
do this
real careful and real slow let me click
over here
yeah my kids might be right all right
oh okay i gotcha um
yeah that show that might show you my my
age
all right so now we need to do a test
uh then we need to learn how to handle
perfect
we're gonna do well actually i'll show
you
about about the continue i remember
when i was first learning i thought we
needed to continue but we actually are
not it's just gonna only break out so
what does break do
that's for those of you that is exactly
right so those of you who haven't seen
break yet
and break is very interesting nope
uh yeah oh oop sorry
break all right
all right so let's look at this
it will only break out one level so if
you have multiple levels
and i'm trying to i think i do have one
somewhere and actually i think i just
came to it but i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna say it because i want to
go double check but whenever you have a
break
it won't break out of the entire
function or the
all of the current loop
the level the way that i like to say it
is the level you're in
so if you have multiple uh
loops and you're indented
that break will only get you out of the
one that it is in you'll still get
kicked over to the previous one
or the one on the outside so it's
um uh you're indented
the body the body that you are currently
in so if i put a break
so if i put a break here it would kick
out of
this loop if i put a break here it would
kick out of this loop we'd stay
in this while loop so if i want to kick
out of the while loop
i would need to have a break here inside
the body
of said condition now we're going to
look at this
and guess what we're going to have
someone
who may not be paying attention or
wants to cause problems absolute with a
break statement
yes yes
move to the next one yes it will make it
it will move out a level
it will move out a level all right so
uh we got y if q
equals in
break now because i want you to think
about it
the loop the while loop is already
continuing
so we actually don't need an else and
i get your structure and i remember when
i was first doing this and then i
started to test and i wanted to see how
how clean and how small and how small
can
short can i write this so now we got a
problem here though
all right because so basically
i want you to look at that so what
happens if
what happens if the person
it's all right we gotta have a problem
here so we go
yes so i get another but now check this
out so then i wanna
what happens if some reason they have
their caps lock on i'm hitting in
i'm hitting in or
in oh no i'm i'm typing that
wait a minute it just went so check this
out
this is the clean and simplest way to do
this
so now uh we talked about lower
we talked about the string
i got my caps lock on str
lower everybody know what lower does
the string method lower has everybody
seen that
before i fly right into this everybody
good
all right i still haven't figured out
how long the delay is on chat
okay all right converts everything
everything to lower
oh caption no caps that that's perfect
all right shoot that's not what i meant
to do
meant to do this
boom brings everything down so
we can actually put this right here at
the end
this is completely legal so
i'm going to take whatever input
okay so what i'm saying is i'm going to
take the input just like we wrapped our
int
around our input now
excuse me i'm going to take my input and
i'm going to lower it so i'm going to
then control
because what you always want to do is
you always want to think about where can
i mitigate
a problem what is the user going to pay
attention are they going to understand
are they going to really get what what
we need so we want to start boxing
those problems in so now i have this
well
what happens if they write no they're
they're not good they're going to get
frustrated if they write no and it fails
so
check this out here's another way so
basically
if
i write nope no
no works so basically anything that
starts with an n
capital or lower click case in in
lowercase n
capital n all caps no nope
anything so basically what happens if
they're coming through
and in their scenario they're used to
whoa
they're used to and they go okay
yes i'd like another one still works
we are mitigating this and shrinking
this down
that anything that even comes close that
starts with an
n then we'll break out so all right
that is that
and this will just go over and over and
over again and we handled
our uh we had handled our padding
very nicely oops let's see oh did we
handle did we go 12 did we solve our
problem yeah um yeah why not let's check
and make sure did we do 15 will that
work
so there we go and i just love times
tables that you just have this
on the edges where these look the same
this was the first thing
i noticed about patterns as a kid where
you just come right through here
and it's the same on either side i just
thought that was just
the coolest thing but if you haven't
figured out yet
i'm very nerdy sorry
we have this all covered so now
now let's move on to prime numbers
let me comment this out because i don't
need to see that anymore
let's come down here and look at all of
this
oops sorry guys
okay prime numbers
who wants to tell me and explain to me
what a prime number is
anybody so
why isn't one a prime number and why is
2 and even
why is was 2 being an odd being an even
number why is it prime
so all right the definition of a prime
number is
a number that is divisible by
one in itself so there in the definition
has to be two numbers one and itself
so a second has to be a second number so
two being the only even prime number
because you have two and then one
prime and everything else is odd so that
is very important to what we're going to
be doing soon so
we're going to be building upon this
uh these things here with our prime
and then i think we're going to that
that flew we flew through that
very very quickly so i think we'll even
get to
what the third idea that i had so i'm
very
actually very excited about this so all
right
we need to go and i want to show you
what i
has anybody ever written a a function of
how to find
if a number is prime or not
anybody done that let's comment this
out
because what we're going to do next is
after we
because i have a feeling we'll be able
to get through the prime very very
quickly
and then what is a awesome exercise
is then can you find
a specific
a quantity of prime can you find
i haven't had the need to so no okay
well
did we do that in session one
oh i'm very embarrassed if we did that
in session one
i don't think so we did even an odd but
we did not do prime
we did an eve oh that's what you were
saying an even check in lesson one yes
yes yes yes
yes we did the even odd check okay so
basically this is just
this is just souped up scenarios so we
then have to go through
we then have to think of every scenario
and then there's even a way to do it
because i remember the first
the first one that i did that worked oh
it was so painful
it was so very very painful what i did
is i made a
i made a list to get
to grab any number that was
divisible and then i went and checked
that list
to see if there was anything in it so
we're going to utilize
our our break because that
this is why i like to then tie these
together
now when i was getting started and
showing i
did not put these lessons together that
they build
wonderfully upon each other so we need
to devise a function
that is going to go through
numbers check start
start at a number go through and then if
that number
is divisible as a divisor
of the number we are checking
our potential prime then it will fail
so i want you to think about this
so we need to then have a way to check
all numbers
in a in a situation in a scenario
in a certain window
what would be the best thing how how how
should we start
what would be the best way to start what
tools do we have so far
to do this because this isn't awesome
because where we're going to go
is we're going to then have a function
that's going to be able to check
any number like if i if i said i want
you to have a function that if i want to
find the 1000th prime number
how would we do that well guess what
we're going to walk
we're going to walk step by step through
this
so if we have a certain number and we
know where we're going to stop
and we know it's divisible we know we
know it is at the end
so basically we're going to go through
we're going to use our range function
and then we know what range does is i
get
a scenario
so here we go so if i want to check and
see if 10 is a prime number
i don't need to do anything here because
i don't need to test it because
i know it's prime then i then i know
that i don't need to if number
greater than 1 for range in
two through number divided by two
if number modulo i
that's pretty good let's see if we can
let's see if we can even short
shorten that up just a little bit but
you are you're right in the ballpark
that is that's pretty good that's that's
that's very good
so we really let's look at this
so let's think about this
so really because i don't need to check
to check 10
i don't need to check one or zero so i
literally only need to check
two through 2 through whatever my number
is
and go from there so these are the
scenarios and i need to then iterate
through this check check this
iterable
and ch divide this into and
as as has already been pointed out if it
is evenly divisible so if it has a
remainder of zero
it's a it's not a prime
because if any of these are a divisor
have a remainder of 0 we're done
we stop we stop checking so if we're
checking 10
we know instantly that it is not a prime
because 2 goes in evenly so we're done
my first program when i did this i had
to go check
all of them then check a list then
then spit it out so let's just look at
this let's look at how
clean and clear and small we can
actually make this
so for i in range
2 through x we just saw that
so now
if i excuse me
if x modulo
i
zero
so now we need to because we're going to
use these as return
we're going to use return here because
we're actually going to use this program
to then build and check
how to find a specific prime so we're
going to use return
so i want you to look at this
oopsie return
false then come out here
return true
it is literally this
this clean and clear all right
because this is what's very cool we i
don't think we've talked about
this yet with return anything where a
return
hits it it exterminates so
you do not remember i remember i was
getting fancy
and uh i i did something like this
oops see how it won't even let you
and that that's how you know
i want you to see this so i'm here at
i'm here at the end of my
uh my return statement and i have i have
a false
and i want to get clever and i want to
put a break here
a python already knows
that everything in this body going below
and even really all of this code is dead
code
whenever a return
is initiated ever everything terminates
everything below it is dead code will
not get to
so you do not need to have a break when
we use return so
that's what we're going to do here but
yes if we were using print
yes we would need to have a break so we
would we would exterminate
and go out so that is 100 correct
but i'm trying to see about uh in that
range function of number
number if number is greater than one and
uh the the floor division of two i'm
trying to wrap my head around that
but here all right so that is our prime
number
and let's go through and just check
let's check this so we have a nice handy
dandy list right here
then we're going to go for num
in test
then print
f bracket num
is a prime number
and then we call the function
i messed this up is prime
just to be consistent so when we're
going to be then we pass it num
and then close this out and then close
that out
oops
so it's changing variables in the middle
of the lesson does
all right 3 is a prime number true
6 is a prime number false 11 is a prime
number true and 31
is a prime number true all right
so does that all make sense of what i
did right there so i took my
i took my new function that i created
i then took a test scenario an interval
i'm iterating through this iterable and
then
i'm printing it out and calling that
function
inside my f string so jan this
is kind of and i don't know if we'll get
to
um multi-line strings but
um this is how you'd handle your
scenario just to give you a little hint
you'd have these brackets in here
and you'd go back and have those
assigned to variables
with whatever scenario you would have
does that make sense
all right okay so now we need to see
and figure out a way of how in the world
we are going to then
track track our
that's not what i need to see sorry
so the two is the first prime number
three is the second and did i have this
up
and uh so we just need to go through
and get started so all right so now
we're going to look
at we're going to look at the nth
how to make an nth prime number function
so def nth
what i call this nth prime
all right so basically the premise of
this is
is if i want the hundredth prime number
how would we do that
so we need a way to so we already know
how to check
if a if a number is a prime
so we need to continue adding numbers so
we need to we need to figure out
how are we going to do this because if
we
well you are you guys are doing a really
good job and you guys ask a lot of good
questions
ask a a lot a lot of good questions
okay so look i will tell you
i bet when i started i was probably
further
further lost than you guys are actually
i'm
i'm kind of intrigued if everybody
wouldn't mind in the chat
commenting how long they've been working
with python i would love to know that
that would be very cool
so all right so we need to just we need
to
we need to decide how we're going to do
this because i remember when i first
started doing this i was like
oh my god so i need to check the first
thousand numbers
that's inaccurate we're counting
a sequence of
oh very cool
well i promise you in the first month
of me trying and learning python um
uh you guys are much further along than
i was at med month one so i wanna i
wanna tell you guys that
and um let you guys know
that is a lot of lines so that is
that is uh that is very that's very
impressive
all right so we need to so we need to
just
we need to figure out how we're going to
be do how we're going to be doing this
well uh i started with c
plus plus a hundred years ago
and i love the idea of programming but i
just could not get it
then uh gosh it's coming up on
eight years ago now i read some articles
and python was in there and i was like
wow i've never heard of this
and i've been off to the races ever
since so all right
but our our nth prime number so
when my brain first went i said okay so
i need to check
i need to figure out if it's in this
span and that's inaccurate
so i need to figure out a way to count
prime numbers
so if it passes this test so i need to
reason why i like doing this right here
is to show you we're going to be using
this inside of this
just like we did up here with our blank
lines
so it's gonna look a lot like this
so as you can see i like to build i like
to build
one thing upon another so it doesn't
become very foreign and we don't go from
hello world
to uh building a machine learn learning
uh
algorithm i like excuse me i like to
take baby steps
so it reinforces what you've learned
and you have a toolbox full of tools
that then you get you get handed any
problem
you know how to do it you want to break
it down you want to break it down into
something that is so simple you can
explain to a five-year-old
if you can explain it to a five-year-old
you can put it in
um python code and have the uh
interpreter work with it all right oop
there we go
so we need to set some rules so one of
the dirty things
one of the dirt one of the dirty rules
about programming
is you have to have a starting point
that's that's one of the dirty little
secrets
you just can't you just can't go you
have to start someplace
so i've alluded to how we're going to do
this
so we have a scenario and you have a
certain set of rules so if i go and i
want to start
at 2 and just to make this to speed this
up
we're going to realize that excluding 2
every every other prime number
is odd all right i'll say that again
excluding 2 every other prime number is
odd
so we're going to count by two so we're
going to speed up our loop
by not checking every number we're only
going to check
the odd numbers so we're going to go by
twos and move on so
that being said we need to we need to
set up our
our our setup to then solve
and plan how to handle this so we're
going to take in our
x number if if i want to find the 100th
prime number
you'd enter that there so
and that's why that looked weird nth
prime that was
all right so we are going to start
at three then our prime
is two so why why am i doing this
because again what is our starting point
so we're gonna we're gonna kind of
push start this um algorithm
so we know the first one is two
and then everything's subsequently
thereafter
starts here and will then increment by
two
every uh every odd number only i we're
gonna
we're gonna start just like we did here
we're gonna remove
any possibility well why in the world
should we be checking
all any any even number because we know
it's not
because it's divisible by two off the
bat so
then that's our starting point so if
somebody enters
one right here
i want to know what the first prime
number is okay
i got you excuse me return
two boom
that handles that scenario so then now
everything there after
shoot let me see if anybody's got
oh yes the
yes the zen of python is actually very
very very very cool
uh do you remember how to import it
while we're talking about this the zen
import what and it just runs
anybody remember
this just this that's how
set up to the top it is it is a python
module
runs right through here yes if you've
not read the zen of python
i highly recommend it it is it is
extremely it's very simple
very clean beautiful is better than ugly
explicit is better than
implicit simple is better than complex
flat is better than nested there you go
so
just wanted to throw that out that is
that is a very good call out
so all right back back to back to our is
prime
so now we need to then figure out
this so while prime so what
what are we what are we testing what are
we what are we wanting to see
how are we going to go about this
so while while what is less
well what is less than this so we
have we have found this is our second
prime number
oh i misspoke this is our second prime
right here
so we're going to have prime be our
counter we could count
so prime we could have had uh
this is our nth prime number this is two
and it is three so while prime
is less than x we need to do something
so if i were to input right now if i
were to input um
two three would come out because
our second prime number
is three does that make sense that's how
we have this we could have set
count and i forgot that i changed that
because we are wanting to
this is the second prime
and we're going to do that going forward
and if you wanted to rearrange this
whatever prime number and then your
count you could but
the way that we're going to build this
is we're going to say
i want this to continue
while this count is less than this
all right so the first thing we need to
do
is it's it's less than this and this is
the second one
so i need to add to this
so num i need to increment oops
by two then
if is prime
number
then prime
plus all right let's go slow let's go
slow
let's come back up here so what am i
doing right here
because we set this up that we're gonna
have this
test oops i didn't drop out did i
okay that's why we're setting this up
because it's going to return create
return create
something and i think uh jan was that
you who made that comment right before
the stream
about in place and um uh
none so my function
is returning creating false
or true so i'm going to have my
condition right here
this is going to this is going to go if
this is going to return either true or
false so then
if true so if this number
num is
prime it's going to come down here and
it's going to
then do something and we're going to
increment
prime by 1.
then we're going to come out here
and i know that i just made a mistake
because
my return didn't go orange
all right so let's check this let me
make sure
do i have a table of
prime numbers let's see 1 000
prime numbers
there we go so all right let's check
this and then we're going to
run it so
let's bring this back
does this make sense to everybody
because most of the time i do this
lesson i want the
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
10th prime number okay that did work
let's click over here
okay all right cool yes uh yeah you were
talking about in play yeah the
the video in place or return are none
in place of none all right so what what
in the world did i just do
so i took a i took a function
i built another function around it and
i'm passing in and creating a test of
how in the world could we check and see
if a number is
prime so then i want to know
the quantity of prime numbers i want to
know what the 10th
prime number is all right
so now what happens if i wanted
oh that's a good one all right i have
another note here
what happens if i wanted a list
of how would this how would
if i wanted a list of all the primes
and this is going to be list
comprehension all right
who said who was saying last week that
list comprehension
is uh is a challenge who is saying that
all right okay so we're gonna put this
in a list comprehension and we're gonna
we're gonna check out okay
well cool how any thoughts
of how in the world we would
it's not all right okay well cool it's
no no no need to have nightmares i
already have some
so let's just go ahead and look at this
i'm going to go primes so we're going to
build a list with list comprehension
so we're going to we're going to get our
brackets
and for i in range
so i'm going to i want to check the
first
100 numbers so
i know one is and if i want the first
100 numbers
i'm going to go to 101. now that's our
that's our header okay
all right are you good there
all right so instead of the body being
underneath
just like so i goes at the beginning
all right this is the order i want you
to think about
making a list comprehension so i have
for i
in range whatever my iterable is
now at the end of it is our condition
and it's literally this simple
if is because now we're going to call
our function
is prime i all right
so let's run this
boom all right
yes shouldn't shouldn't there be i for i
absolutely
and if you're to that point where you
can just flow that out
that is absolutely fine but i like to
show
the the way to to deconstruct
a for loop header and body
than to do it in that order so you have
your
your header your then your then your
iterable
your excuse me your itter here's your
iterable
forgive me for misspeaking then here's
your iter and then here's your condition
so your your itter goes in front of the
four
all right is that a little bit better is
that that oh is that a little bit
less nightmarish and i get it i remember
the first time i saw this especially
with scenarios and then you have these
over here
and you start doing stuff to this and
it's just like
i don't get it and then there's actually
more well because a lot of people like
to show off and just
good that's the point people then jump
into this and they have
net a nested list comprehension
i'm not going to show you a nested list
comprehension for
a while because sometimes that's can be
a little extra
extravagant but maybe next week we can
show
speed i think that's a good idea because
now we're going to work
on our guessing game this went a lot
faster
than i wanted to so now we're going to
build upon this
and you could even go and build this and
have
a a list of a scenario
of until this is 1000
so that would be
well you guys you guys are awesome and
like i said i want you to
well cool but i want you guys to
understand
i promise you you guys are much further
along
than i was at a month i know it i mean
if you're already
uh building uh a bot i i didn't even
understand what that was
and having to have i mean it took me
forever to get what a module was i mean
when the first time i saw this i said
well how how did they get this to come
out well
it's in the file what what file oh this
is the name of the file
no it's called this yeah i know that's
the name of the module this
so trust me just spit in the just
said spend the time i don't know if you
guys uh
watched the video yesterday on my
channel
but i promise you just show up and
look you guys are here every week you
guys are getting this you guys are
asking a lot
of great questions you guys are doing
good all right cool let's go ahead and
jump into
our guessing game
so we got a lot
of cool stuff to deal with the guessing
game
all right let's comment this out because
we don't delete code right everybody
we don't delete anything of code
all right guessing game so we are going
to
need to come up with how we're going to
do this
so we got to where our first problem is
a random number right
how do we do random numbers
anybody remember
what tools do we have to get us a random
number going
oh i lost my
so we need to get
import random
random yep
and then which which one to deal with
random
oh my goodness i am so sorry everybody
all right if i just want
one random number let's say from 1 to 20
what do i use
763 lines of code
sequences pick random elements pick
random sample
uniform within range uh
let's see
anybody remember randy int
randy ant that's okay
uh
[Music]
so
so randent is
okay oops there's another comment
rand because then random range
we'll deal with that later but randint
is sufficient so we need to
uh pick and have
have our number
equals
brand int
and how to remind remind everybody what
does randint do
this is the only time that
that i can believe has
that b is inclusive and i want you to
look right here
this is this is math and only if
you're nerdy math like me you get so
open open a bracket and a parenthesis
tells you the
yes and that's fine that's again you
don't know these things until you know
these things
and i mean i couldn't remember i could
not remember anything
but you do this stuff 10 hundred
hundreds of times you just you just know
what to do i mean you may not know that
everybody wants to go and get a hammer
the first time they're
working on tools and a certain type of
screwdriver
well then you learn that there's more
sophisticated tools and you go from
there
again you don't know what you don't know
they're called unknown unknowns well
we're trying to remove as many unknown
unknowns as possible
so here we go we have our we have our
first problem solved well guess what we
need to have something go
over and over and over and over again so
we're going to go 1 through 20.
so we need to do something until
something stops
so guess what we're going to do while
true
now let's see
what'd we learn last time of how it um
would we learn how to handle last time
taking input from the user
if it's if it's wrong so we need to get
ahead of that right now
so we're going to try
accept and what was our
what was our exception
all right
oops please enter
a number
and i made a boo-boo i should have put
pass here just in case something
happened
so all right passes hey i know i have a
header
and now i have
you can in this situ in this very
small situation but
you guys are already sophisticated
enough that i want you to get into the
habit of this when i have people who
don't even get this concept
at all i just have them do accept
but that habit is then you do that
and you grab all exceptions well
you want to be as focused as possible
and what we just learned about
this
explicit is better than implicit so with
us putting here
value error we are explicitly catching
that one error
and we will hopefully we'll have time
and we can work together and we can grab
other errors and more sophisticated but
then you just have these
go through but you can you can
but just want to be clean and clear
and explicit in everything that
we code and especially the things that i
want to show you i would probably
show that on my channel i think i've
done that before but
here on free code camp i want to make
sure that i'm showing you guys
the best the best of best practices no
no no no whitewashing the fence
so all right so let's just go ahead and
uh finish it out so now okay
so now we need to so we have we have the
computer
it's grabbing a number so what is the
point of this we went now we're going to
do
tests of we want to
compare what the what the computer
picked
to what to what
we're going to guess so first of all so
we can really kind of
make sure that this works we're going to
cheat a little bit
and we're going to have this print out
on the screen
awesome nice catch thank you
so we're going to cheat and also we want
to make sure that our tests and our
scenarios
are correct so we're going to print out
the number
but now we need to take input from the
user to compare right
so we're going to have the guess oops
the guess then what is our all-time
problem that we have int
input would i say please
enter a guess
all right so now here's here's where the
fun starts
now why'd that happen anybody know
because i can't count
so i know that that's now there saboom
okay
so now we are
so let's check this
17. so first let's handle our first
problem
oops please enter a number 17. all right
so here's our here's our first dilemma
that i guess 17 and nothing happened
so let's handle that first so we can get
ahead of that
and we're gonna have some excitement
with this
and uh it's the reason why i like
this exercise so much is you've really
got to
you really have to understand workflow
and you can make it extremely
complicated
or if you're like me you like to make
things super super simple
so you can remember how to do it so we
have
a while loop and then we need to
learn how to handle this actually
no we need to handle one other thing we
need to actually then have
a second while loop yeah sorry got ahead
of myself
you guys you guys are so good and smart
i get so excited
and i get ahead of myself i think it was
last week yeah where we started doing uh
i almost forget what yeah i need to go
back and look at my notes and actually
see because i
i think we skipped i think we skipped
what i kind of wanted to talk about
because uh we got into the um
yeah i need to go back and check because
uh we got into the uh
horse race and that was very cool that's
one of the uh 25 horses
yeah if you guys missed last last week's
that was very cool
we uh we did some cool stuff that was an
interview question i ran across
a while ago it's probably not one
anymore because everybody knows the
answer
all right so now we need to have
a loop here so while
guess not equal and
old sam would be having a panic attack
right now
so all right so what we what we're doing
right here
is we need this loop
okay kind of cheat a bit and use my
notes
and that's fine that's fine look it's
not cheating
to go back and look what you it's your
work it's what you've done
i still google stuff
all the time oh my gosh what does that
do what's this error
look i i read this one
tweet that um from this data scientist i
spend more time
googling my errors than writing code
look if you're not taking somebody
else's work it's not cheating
so if you're having to look up an error
if you're having to look back at your
notes
that's the point of this is to go oh i
don't remember exactly how i did it but
i know i did it but i know i have it
here that's why you don't throw anything
away that's why you don't delete
anything and that's why you
definitely see save things to the cloud
and make sure you never
yeah don't don't leave any code
that that that's funny well then you can
uh check out uh free code camp all their
awesome videos or
python basics for all all of uh
those things because that that's the
that's the point and that's what beau
and i were
talking about about having all of these
lessons that i have
all compressed into streams that
everyone can come back and watch all
right
i digress so but the reason why i
would have had or old sam would have a
panic attack is
true and false was already um bad enough
and then now we have a knot here but the
way that i was
okay and was able to comprehend this is
you're going to do this
as long as this is wrong so that's what
i want you to think about
you're going to continue prompting the
guess
of you're going to check you're going to
continue to check because if it's
not because you have how many scenarios
do do we have
any any thoughts we have we have we have
certain number of scenarios and we have
to handle each of those so right now
we're handling any improper input so we
actually have
uh i don't
i got you
that's funny all right so we actually
have four scenarios
bad input
correct guess guess is too high and
guess is too low
so we actually have four bad input solve
that
uh right now we're going to handle it if
it's not
the right guess so we we can just go
ahead
and and start there
all right so uh
if guess is greater than
number sorry if i guessed
if the guess is greater okay the guess
is greater
please
please do
please and please
guess a smaller
number i don't know if we want to put a
sentence on there all right
so that's part of it then i'm going to
then
take another guess right
and then or here let's just let's go
slow
print
so that we have guesses too
large so then we need to do
hang on hang on i missed a couple
cool yep
well yeah jan i don't know if that was
you or
we but yes we we got this right here
then we have so i think it was our
scenario where we had a
nested so it's not right
and then we have then two subcategories
of not right
we're either too high or too low so then
we need to handle
these two and two of them is a slam dunk
we got an
if and an else so then please
guess a
larger number
all right now we've got a little bit of
a problem so it's one
okay i'm guessing one and
here's our problem anybody see it it's
just continuously going
so what do we need to do
that's just running and we're now 20
62. so we need to re-prompt
right all right
i know i know i know i know i know i
know
i finally found a scenario that it's
okay to copy but don't copy
okay i even i even messed up i don't
even let myself copy
uh okay you think
we'll get there all right
so five smaller number three okay
guess a larger number all right so those
two work
those two work so then i guess four
but then i'm all right so here we go
so this is how we're going to then so
you could then
test you could do an elif but i want to
show you something that is
very cool and i'm going to show you
something
else so
um
all right
guessed the correct
number this is what is very cool
about this and not a lot of people are
shown this
and then we're going to handle just like
we did last time
all right so it's 10 so i'm going to
guess
8 guess a larger number 11 guess a
smaller number 10.
okay but now i need
oops
and then
right here
so what we did is then we need to then
have
a issue right here
of do we want to play again so we get
out of here
because i'm up here guessing
because i'm going to show you this i
forgot i changed this
to inside the try so now we need to do a
question
and i'll show you the scenario why we
need to put it here
put you can do the break
it will work but i just want to give you
yes because while this is what i want
you to think about
while true
right what does else do what does else
grab
else grabs the false right
bingo so that's why we are pairing the
while and the else and then we need to
then test here
to get out of this loop because
in my original because look this is a
perfect example
is i've written this
probably 20 30 times over and over and
over again and
mate actually that might be something
neat because we're gonna have a little
bit of time i will show you some of my
old garbage code
to just because look i can say it
that you guys are much further along
here's a looping alternative yes
absolutely that's the way i want you to
think about it
else is the the other option
bullion you have two choices i think i'm
in frame i need to learn about where i
am
you have either true or false and that
is the basis
of a processor that circuit is either
open
or closed everything else builds from
there all right that's what i want you
to think about
you have to think about very binary
can i get this down to binary or as
close to or then start alleviating
all right so yeah that might be
something cool to do so i'm going to
show you this
i did not think i needed to build all
this at one time and then i'll show you
exactly why
we could put this outside the loop but
then we have an
error and you'll get a bug
and those sometimes are so fun to find
i remember the first time i built the
times table i
actually that might be cool i might show
you the
i think i didn't break my rule yet and
have this all
to play again
all right yes no
do do do do then what what do we what do
we learn how to do
lower than if q
0 equals
lower in break
all right there we go so we got
kicked we're kicked out of here kicked
out of here right
uh okay 11 guess higher 13
guess lower 12. you guessed correct
would you like to play again
no awesome it worked
all right oop that's not where i want to
go
now now let's show you i remember
uh one iteration i ran through was that
while i was getting my notes around so
i looked at it and i go
well i don't need this because i think i
was i was wanting to
i was wanting to see how dependent
this was so let's
comment that
copy this and i think i put it here
yes so it gets outside of my exception
so i said okay let's check this and i
think
let's see see if i can do this on
purpose
um ah and there's one more bug that i
almost forgot about that we need to then
handle
because right now
sorry i really like working with you
guys i am very sorry sometimes i
maybe at some point i will get so used
to you guys asking some really good
questions
and um i won't i won't get as
uh get as excited but no you guys you
guys are phenomenal
you guys are great great students great
learners
and really good questions so
now i've moved this down here this is
going to create a bug and i'm going to
show you why let me
let's see if i can make sure i do this
on purpose
okay all right so 15
17 16.
ah shoot i thought
ah here we go all right
so i want to i have to rethink about
what that bug
is all right let me show you this
problem oops please enter yes
so everybody look at what that number is
right now so
i'm going to go 6 7 oops 9
8. you want to play again yes
huh what are the odds that it's still
eight
yes okay now this is
becoming astonishingly
was that it did i get it to do it
okay all right what are the odds
that our guess is ate every single time
anybody have any guesses of why what
flow
shift down there
[Music]
um
okay all right all right let's talk
about
the bug that and i can't get the other
bug to work
um here but i just wanted to show you uh
this let's comment that out
actually it might it might show up here
all right
so did anybody notice that i got
eight is the random number every single
time
anybody notice that so
how do we solve that anybody see the
problem in my code
anybody see it yet
here so i'm in this loop going over and
over and over again
but this is not so this needs to be here
see where it needs to go
right inside right here
so now when i guess
should i play again yes 17
oh yeah 147 so is that guess the smaller
number 17
would you like to play again yes so now
this is where it needs to be
actually let's check and uncomment this
out and see if
this grabs it all right uh
nine oh i know what it is now hang on
this is this is the problem so if i hit
no
here um
okay i guess the bug is gone
i could have sworn that was it but yes i
did want to show you
this right here and you're exactly right
this is a true and if it becomes false
grabs here alrighty so
no that is that so we have about
36 minutes
generating remember inside the wall abso
absolutely
right we needed to move that down if we
wanted this to truly
truly repeat all right let me see where
we
are with
this well we went
so much faster all right
this is a good one
did we do leap year yet anybody talk
about
okay let's look over and comment do do
have we done leap year
jan does anybody alright you guys know
lee pierce
all right who knows the definition of a
leap year
i bet you a nickel you do not know
because i thought i knew and i turned
out i did not know
so i thought i would have bet any amount
of money
that i could explain what a leap year
was and i would think i was
40. so three years ago and i learned
that i did not know
what a leap year is anybody want to try
for a nickel
and i will
oh okay
a leap year is
a year exactly
what are the what's the what's the rule
for a leap year
i'm sorry i wasn't saying what's what's
a rule for a leap year
any comment any thoughts because the
first guess that everybody tells me
and i would have and i said the exact
same thing i would have said the exact
same thing
it is a year that is divisible by four
that is partially true
there are two more there are two more
scenarios
so first has to be then
almost happens every four years
so the
so 2000 was a leap year right
i don't know if you guys you guys were
more than likely alive but maybe not
that old
so 2000 was a leap year
is everybody aware of that but also 1900
was not so here's the rules and we need
to build
we need to build a function of
let me get over we're going to build a
function to test this
so all right so 2000
was a leap year but now here's the
kicker
1900 was not a leap year
and the reason why is because
it is divisible by
100 and not divisible
by 400. so i'll say that
a couple of different ways so when you
get to the century mark
it's every 400 years so i get to tell my
kids my kids were going a little bit
after 2000
that i'm the first one to have
to have a leap year on a century since
1600.
so here we go so here's the rule of
so sixteen hundred was a leap year
because it is divisible by four
sixteen hundred divisible by one hundred
and sixteen hundred divisible by four
400.
that is the definition of a leap year
so 1900 is not
a leap year
because once it is divisible by 4
by 100 it then immediately has to be
divisible by
400 and you have a remainder of 3.
so that is the rule every single year
is divisible by
every every year that's divisible by 400
excluding the century marks
are except every 400 years
now let's build a function to test that
is everybody's mind blown right now
because i remember the first time and i
would have bet
any amount of money for any value
and i would have been mad about it that
i could have told somebody what
what uh what a leap year was
all right we ready to do this
okay so we need to go slow and we need
to get this figured out
so we got leap year
so what'd we learn we we just learned so
uh 1992 we're gonna check then 1600
and 1900 2000
and then we'll check 2020.
what do we think about that does that
sound pretty good
i won't i won't uh i won't take it from
you but
that's one of those things that you keep
walking around i remember
uh i remember i told my dad about it and
he
he wanted to get he wanted to get mad he
he does not like it when i know things
uh that he does not
and this is why i don't enter yeah i
look i don't
i don't i don't bet but i i would have
like i said
i would have bet any amount of money i
don't but
um all right so we need to go
we need to go and think about this this
is going to be
this is going to be fun so you guys you
guys help me
how are we going to do this
leap year so we're going to test a year
so we got that set up so what's our
first
what's our first scenario
so it has to be what
before we before we even waste any time
right
how should w what should go here i guess
i can pull this over we don't have any
more
lots of documentation we have to do all
right what what should go here
divisible by four all right if year
modulo four equals
zero all right so now
all right good
okay then what what'd we learn
now here's where the true and false get
real fun
real fast
i think i can have these ooh i don't
need to see me
somebody type okay all right
all right so then now
all right so let's look let's get this
um we'll do pass
then we'll get this uh
oh you want to do that one already cool
all right so if
then x divisible by 100
equals zero then what
then what so i like how you're doing
this okay
so we're we're just we're just going
through then so
we got 400 then we checked 100
then okay
if
400
yep so
4 100 400
it's a it's a leap year right
return true okay
who's ready to do a bunch of else's
oops all right
so huh didn't think
oh no need to get that nope because it's
just
a it's just a scenario it's just a one
one time one time scenario you don't
have to go through
thank you
all right great catch all right
so we have our first true
so then inside this which one will this
be
else
what
what's this one
exactly all right so we'll work our way
back
out so if this scenario
boom all right so then i back out one
more right
what's this one
any thoughts
it's a little backwards
look you guys i'm gonna have to start
hiring you guys
to be my copy uh my editors
alright so what is this else
other than you guys checking my my
spelling
all right so then we go
okay so then this is weird
okay
return true
else
return false
all right so let's look at this
and let me check mine true false true
false it looks weird but let's go
through it
so now we have let's build this so we're
going to check
these up here here are my years years
equals we throw these in 1992
1600 1900
2002 2020.
okay all right
so four year in years
and that's fine look look you guys i
would have
never ever ever participated in a chat
on when i was learning especially at a
month
i'd have been terrified look you okay
if you if you haven't seen the video uh
yesterday i'll
try not to take it personally but look
you only get better if you stretch your
stretch your wings all right look you
have got
to mess up and especially when you're i
want you to think about this
we are completely pushing the limits of
technology every single day
and they don't happen because of we
accidentally just it showed up no
we tried something we broke it we tried
something it didn't go
it went horribly wrong i drive my kids
nuts when i talk about the quote from
thomas edison he does not say he
discovered how to
create a light bulb excuse me he doesn't
say he invented a light bulb he
discovered
the way that a light bulb worked he
removed
all the other options that were wrong
and the only thing that was left
was a light bulb over ten thousand
experiments
of what didn't work he happened he
removed all of them it's like a
sculpture
i want you to think about that the
sculpture is there inside the rock
michelangelo used to say that all all
the time
all i do is remove the excess you have
got to try something
break it and learn from it and go from
there all right
i know i just went off and off and
hopefully not a lot of people just quit
bo won't let bo won't let me back all
right okay
so here we are um
print leap
year
uh year did i call the right variable
okay and i close that out and know what
i do wrong
and i did not close it out okay
otherwise man once told me if you ask a
stupid question
you only like until you hear the answer
yeah uh if you don't ask it you'll lack
knowledge for the rest
absolutely i i remember when i
a lot of parents struggle with why
because
it it takes a lot of time and it's a lot
of energy it is a lot of energy
all right so let's look at i guess i
should you know what i should do
so i should probably have year printed
there and we could put that in our handy
dandy
f string maybe we can do that in a
minute but all right uh
why why why why why why i love that
question now
i love that because look you only get
better if you ask why and if somebody
you're working with doesn't tell you why
uh
absolutely i could not i could not say
that better
i want you guys to grow i have the
greatest time being here and i
am being extended the wonderful
opportunity of
um having being on this channel
that um quincy
and bo are allowing me and i just hope
that
you guys are all getting something out
of this not just
programming but stretching yourself
pushing yourself
uh and going from there so all right
uh here we got we got 1992
true 1600 false
1900 true um
ooh no that is backwards
hang on oh my goodness
what'd i do wrong
false false true oh we need to fix that
well here we go guys where did i
let me check my stuff over here
oh will this come over here
oops yeah i want to kill it sorry i need
to
uncomment this out
and run this
true false true
oh anybody else catch my awesome
awesome mistake
there we go
here we go okay again you guys
i can't blame that stuff on you anymore
you guys are you guys are awesome all
right
so guess what i left out a very big
important scenario right here
of testing that this is
a true false
true false and this is back supposed to
be true
let's check this again false
false true true true
there we go because if you missed it
and i cannot believe i did that but i
left
out a condition of equal to zero this
modulo equal to zero so all right we got
about 18 minutes let's
uh let's jump on something new so we
just did
just did that um let's see
pull this up is that going to pull over
[Music]
there
so i can open that let's bring that over
here because we flew through
through these a lot faster than
i was imagining so
ideas i'm looking for
h i that's not right
let me say bear with me guys
like i said you guys are
uh fantastic okay actually here's here's
some
here's some pretty good stuff oh hang on
all right he's playing tricks on us
always with the small things oh
absolutely uh well
i can talk to i can speak to that uh a
ton
so i well my spelling hasn't improved
uh maybe marginally but my typing has
and also
if i haven't said this yet i
became much more sharp-minded
by having to focus on making sure the
variables matched up
and making sure i was typing correctly
um
and the speed of typing my and i know
i'm not a fast typer i'm not
i'm not saying anything like that but i
am much faster
than i was before so let's actually look
at a couple of things
so let's take a list
and i don't think we have done
this yet so we have
we have a list of names
and we're going to go
let me just grab these names copy them
put them over here
so i'm going to show you the long way
and then i'm going to show you some of
the
built-in functions
well yes my younger son he has a
mechanical keyboard
and he loves sometimes the clicking just
absolutely drives me
bananas but all right so let's look at
another way
so we have for name name
in names
print name right all right
well i'm going to show you how to think
about this
because there's going to be times
there's going to be a time at some point
and you're going to need to know how to
think about this and going through and
thinking about the
the the index i don't think we've done
he's trying to kill his keyboard that's
funny all right
so then we go lynn
lynn names
so let's look at this blend names
when names all right would that do
and if i could get an s in here for the
love of all that is good
it's all right let's look at this for a
second
so i think i showed you this
so when you call der without anything
you see everything that's in memory
right now
right so we got horses sitting around
out there we got name we got names we
got numbers we got race we got random we
got shuffled
so name is the last
iter here so i accidentally ran lynn
on name and steve happens to
be the length of five well i want the
land of names
i promise guys i will figure this out
three because there's three items inside
names and we do help
on len and we get return
turn number of items in a container all
right so string is even a container
hang on what is it
oh that's messed up that's the keyboard
killed his father
okay all right so now so since this is
a since th this is
another garbage collection video
yes i uh was that you that asked about
it i could not remember
yes i um that was very intriguing
i i think that would be a very good idea
i don't think that would blow
everybody away because actually that's
kind of my claim to fame
um i actually made a tweet um
a long time ago and
um gordo uh hearted it
because that was actually the one of the
premises there's tons of
premises of why python became python and
was created
but it was so memory
allocation was not important it was
it was going to take that away from the
user to
enable the excuse me the the the
programmer
to um to be more free and it would
it would free up time and be able to
because that's
that's one of the things that stumped me
with c
plus plus and just of just a variety of
things
but that that was that was um one of the
points was memory control
and memory allocation that was one of
the top
priorities of it so yes i actually think
that's a very good idea
and i don't think it will be over
too many people's heads and especially
all of these
awesome new subscribers that um i've
gotten but yes i will get some stuff
around
because i don't think a ton of people
are super interested in the django
um series so i'm gonna try to wrap that
up as fast as possible
and then we'll move on to some other
cool stuff have really gotten some
really good really cool suggestions but
all right i digress let's finish this
out in the next 12 minutes
so since this is a number an int
and so then we can wrap this
because again this is completely legal
because python understands
it goes hey you know what you're talking
about you're passing a number
in here and we're going from here so now
so now i still get um
names
here we go so
i'm gonna go here apparently i will
never
use names again since i cannot
um keep the difference between name and
names
all right so this is completely legal so
now
we're going to have somebody looking at
this and they're gonna go zero that
sam is zero there's zero person so guess
what this is how we solve this
one plus
one completely legal
because again python goes hey
you know what you're talking about
completely legal oops there we go
now
now let's look at um
check this out so i so we need to change
this to i since we got rid of names
that's more clear so
but let's come back over here
and look at this again lend
names nailed it all right
so we got 0 1 2. so down here we're
going to solve it here
so check this out 1 2
3 4.
names
i alright so what are we doing
anybody anybody got any guesses
so i'm actually using the range function
to index through
now that was a lot of work to show you
this
has anybody seen the built-in function
that does this exact same thing that i
just did with the tools that we have so
far
any i almost want to say anyone anyone
but i doubt
anybody i don't know if bo or quincy are
still watching
to get that reference i might send some
real money if anybody gets that one
that is an old movie from my error
index bingo i am indexing
fantastic so now oh
yes i'm using index oh i see what you're
saying index
has anybody seen enumerate anybody seen
the enumerate
um function anybody seen that yet
does this exact same thing just we don't
have to do any extra
thinking
okay all right we need to figure out
a better way to faster not better the
chat's good
i've used it but you haven't shown it
okay
well what does it do
and that is very helpful that you guys
can help me
eight what does it do
it's actually very cool so it shows the
index value and value
bingo what does it create
so you have an interval starting point
creates a pair where's the default
anybody know that if i say default what
do i mean
what information
you have tuple very good creates a tuple
because whenever you see pairs and then
it even hints right there
defaults to zero so all right let's
check this out
so we got names right then we got
let's just do new i remember numer
or eight names
new i remember i spent more time
just forgot this
new equals list
new new forgot that part
all right bam
check this out so uh then when i do
new
up new
index zero wrap that tuple
very good so what this does and
all right so default argument keyword
argument
um but it is uh
default to zero already set
so it starts at zero
but i could come in here
and change this
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah let's do
this
this is good have we done packing and
unpacking yet anybody
got a couple minutes we'll get we'll get
into this
oop and i just broke my own rule all
right
comment that out for
i in enumerate
hey all right
names starts at zero i want to start at
one
sorry one
print i so what am i going to do right
here
i get a tuple
i did not talk about packing and
unpacking awesome okay
uh five minutes i think i think we can
do packing and unpacking in five minutes
so we have a pair
these are set together
so i right now because it's our last
item so i is still there so
num and name
equals i
uh what i what did i just do
i it didn't throw an error so something
is completely legal
so i just unpacked this because i
i is a tuple
has a len of
two i passed it
two variables python goes in
breaks this down unpacks
assigns because it's just like this
just like that so i want you to think
about this so i
is this
just like this so i have x
and then y and it goes in
and just links the two of these together
oh very cool well that's awesome
and unpacks this next video we'll look
at we'll look at uh
packing back but this unpacks this
so so if i have i
right here and each time through
this is this is a set
this is a tuple so let's run this again
oops sorry
so this is my tuple so now
i can come over here
copy paste comment
num name
all right so what
don't don't overthink this same
so what this is is this is unpacking
this item print
num name
go through boom so there we go
i think that is a fantastic starting
point and i promise promise
promise and i'm gonna save this right
now i did not
save the
um the file the shell
the first time but i did shave shave
save the file they the shell um
shell shave save the shell
wow say that three times fast save the
shell the first time but i did save the
shell
the of everything that i typed in the
meantime so we'll at least have that
and i will be doing that going forward
but
absolutely awesome stream today i really
hope you guys
are having as much fun as i am because i
really
i really get a lot out of this and i
have a grand
grand time so i just want to tell you
all
thank you very much um i really truly
enjoy these
anything that you've seen here i've
tried to have a more
in-depth video over on my channel so if
there's anything
you want to see just bounce over there
thank you everybody for spending time
quincy and bo thank you for extending
me this wonderful opportunity and we'll
just keep going and we will see where
this goes
but as always guys thanks for watching
stay tuned
and we will see you guys next week
bye guys